Der Aletsch in fast 3.000 Metern Höhe.
Die Schweiz hat so viele Gletscher,
dass man eine ganze Bahnstrecke
daran vorbeilegen kann.
Und die beginnt in St. Moritz, dem
berühmten Skiort im Kanton Graubünden.
Von hier aus startet regelmäßig der
Gletscher-Express Richtung Zermatt
- und nur ein paar Mal im
Jahr die Nostalgie-Variante:
der Glacier Pullman Express.
Gut 50 Gäste machen es sich gemütlich
in den alten Pullman-Wagen
aus den 1930er Jahren.
Für die kaum mehr als 240 Kilometer,
die der reguläre Glacier-Express
in nur acht Stunden zurücklegt,
nimmt sich der Nostalgiezug
zwei Tage Zeit.
Die Strecke führt durch 91
Tunnel und über 291 Brücken.
Auf Schmalspurschienen schlängelt
sich der Glacier Pullman Express
von St. Moritz am ersten
Tag bis Andermatt,
zunächst über die „Albulabahn“.
Als eine von nur drei
Eisenbahnstrecken weltweit
darf sie sich mit dem Titel
UNESCO-Welterbe schmücken.
Gezogen werden die Nostalgie-
Waggons von einer Nostalgie-Lok.
Christoph Rohner steuert seine Krokodil-
Lokomotive aus den 30er Jahren
im gemächlichen Tempo durch Kurven,
Tunnel und über Viadukte.
Je älter die Lokomotive ist, je [desto]
mehr ist das ein Handwerk.
Ich muss da alles selbst überwachen,
ich muss auf Geräusche hören,
(auf) Temperaturen
überwachen und so weiter,
das macht bei einer modernen
Lok alles der Computer.
Gegen Mittag erreicht der Glacier
Pullman Express das Rheintal.
Hier, wo der mächtige
Strom noch jung ist,
wird in den Restaurantwagen
Mittagessen serviert.
Beim anschließenden Grappa
kommt es darauf an,
dass trotz Schaukelei kein
Tropfen daneben geht.
Schweizer Präzision trifft im
Glacier Pullman Express
auf Schweizer Eisenbahn-Tradition.
Die Eidgenossen sind ein
Volk von Bahnfahrern.
Wir sind Weltmeister, leider nicht im
Fußball, wird vielleicht nie werden,
aber wir sind Weltmeister im Zugfahren,
und da dürfen wir auch stolz sein.
Der Schweizer hat immer ein bisschen
Mühe, seinen Stolz zu zeigen, ja?
Es gibt keine Nation, die mehr
Zug fährt als die Schweizer,
wir haben den längsten
Eisenbahntunnel in der Schweiz,
aber die Schweizer können das
nicht zeigen. Die dürfen mal stolz sein, ja.
Die Gäste jedenfalls genießen es.
Und so trödelt der langsamste Expresszug
der Welt durch den Nachmittag.
Übernachtet wird übrigens nicht im Zug,
sondern in bequemen Hotelbetten.
Der zweite Tag der Reise
beginnt mit ordentlich Dampf
– und mit einem ganz anderen Zug:
Am Furkapass bei Andermatt muss der
Glacier Pullman Express den Tunnel nehmen.
Die Passagiere aber erleben
Eisenbahnromantik pur
– mit der mehr als 100
Jahre alten Furkabahn.
Steil hinauf geht es per Zahnradantrieb bis
zum Pass auf über 2.000 Meter Höhe,
wo auch Mitte Juli noch Schnee liegt.
In der Schweiz ist es
ein stetes Auf und Ab.
Vom Furkapass geht es steil
wieder hinunter ins Tal.
Von dort aus sind es nicht mehr
viele Kilometer bis nach Zermatt,
der größte Teil der Strecke ist geschafft.
Doch ein Gipfelgenuss steht noch aus,
der Aletschgletscher.
Im Örtchen Fiesch heißt es
deshalb wieder: umsteigen!
Seilbahn ist schließlich auch eine Bahn.
Besuch beim UNESCO-Weltnaturerbe.
Der Aletsch ist der größte
und längste Gletscher der Alpen.
Unten im Tal verschwindet die
Gletscherwelt hinter Wolken,
während der Glacier Pullman
Express Richtung Matterhorn fährt.
Auch das wird sich
heute in Dunst hüllen.
Schade, aber kein Grund für Trübsal.
Sehr gemütlich, es ist so …
vom hektischen Alltag,
man kann sich da so richtig erholen und so
mal runterkommen, die Natur genießen.
Kein Stress, schön gemütlich, gutes
Essen haben wir auch genossen.
Also ich würde das sofort wieder machen.
So geht die langsame Reise
doch schnell zu Ende.
Einfahrt in Zermatt mit dem
langsamsten Schnellzug der Welt.
Ein Anti-Stressprogramm auf Schienen.